I've no idea what's going on, but I've got the live going by, and I was like, 2.30,
that's not 3 minutes, I don't know what's going on.
10 times 4.
I also, um, okay there we go, I think that's me up.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
I just want to start off the stream and say I'm an absolute agony, there's something wrong with my digestive tract right now.
No, it's not ketchup season before anyone gets excited, I don't know who would get excited about ketchup season.
I basically went to sleep with the store stomach, I've woken up with the store stomach, I still don't feel good,
I'm not really sure what the dealio is, but I'm just going to hame a water, hame, have my water, and then have you tried a jove,
I don't know if it's that.
We are on Xbox, we are officially getting GamerScore.
Right, tutorial first.
Even though the tutorial in this game was so hard for no reason.
I'm right into it, I don't, you know the folks that have a loading screen for ages?
We are literally on an Xbox 360 right now, like streaming to it.
I might be able to open up my GamerScore and it'll be like 120 from Skyrim.
No love, all love, unfortunately I'm just a bit sore, I don't know what the result of the stream is going to be.
Right, so this beautiful game was created by Rare Studios and it was probably one of the first fantasy games I ever played.
And it was, it just completely captured everything I want in a Wii video game.
Yeah, damn it's loading.
But I hope you guys are doing okay.
As for any behind the scenes stuff, my collab with Denpa is out on Patreon only access.
I'm just waiting for her to send a PNG of her and her beautiful tentacles and then I can render out the video.
And, oh my gosh, I have my lovely pommel route.
Look at how many gamys are floating around.
Oh, there's Grows.
I didn't know anyone else that played this game.
I'm an Xbox child, what can I say?
So we have three elemental warriors, we have Chinchilla, we have Pommel wheat and we have our beautiful major ruin.
You have to say it, you can't just say it's major ruin, you have to go major ruin or else it doesn't count, okay?
Demand?
Oh, the water temple used to make me so nervous, like I couldn't handle it.
Now, I will say one thing, before anyone's expecting it, there's a bit of delay between me and the Xbox receiving this.
So the game pass, you also, instead of downloading the game and playing it on your end, the game pass basically streams to an Xbox.
Sorry, I thought you were just going to go three times there, I just wasted a bit of time there, but whoopsie.
I love these older games.
So I recently tweeted out, I was like, thanks for the first month of streaming, and then I looked at it and I'm like, wait a minute, these are all games I've already played.
I like, listed, I was like, well, my favorite game was Boutro, I really liked it and I really enjoyed their buckshot.
For you, this side my child would like to hear, such a fun game.
Galo, why can't I not see that?
What the heck, why can't I hear that but not see that?
Well, that was weird.
I was like, Brian, but I don't see any Brian, hello?
Galoglass, thank you for the tech, for real, it's my childhood game, it's such a fun game.
Literally, it's such a pretty fun to see game as well, sorry, but this game was made for, I don't know, really happy good times, okay, because I deserve it.
Now, I'm pretty sure I can't just ace a Corvus guy.
I see that guy in the distance coming towards me, I don't know what he's doing.
Okay, our objective, oh, well, that was our objective actually was to throw him in the fire.
Right, yes, my behind the scenes update, unfortunately, because I wasn't very well, the only thing I did yesterday was edit my collab with Denpa.
Originally, I was going to do the Freya collab, but sadly, I had trouble opening up the file, so I had to get it converted.
Was that a bad guy or not?
As if a meteor just comes from the sky and wallops me, that's outrageous.
Take it back right now, that's my XP you absolutely can have it gone.
We nearly got a sequel, but the game didn't sell, don't, don't, I didn't know that.
Don't break my heart.
You tell me, we can have that cameo too, are you joking?
I had no idea about that, like truly.
But yes, we were playing a young fairy, fairy confirmed for Gentoo by the way.
The fact that none of yous will know, I'm trolling with what I say with confirmed too.
Can I tell you the truth, I've actually said like as a joke, oh, this thing confirmed for Gentoo, but it actually isn't Gentoo.
And you guys aren't going to know until we reveal the designs.
It's absolutely evil, empty head, no thoughts, thank you for becoming a member.
It's absolutely evil, but I have actually said things as a joke that are confirmed.
But I've said so much at this point, there's no way you're going to be able to follow what the dealio is.
Now it's a lot easier to skirt this bridge as cameo, but there is a guy up ahead that pu pu pu, little bombas here.
Cameo's hitbox is obviously quite significantly smaller than a lot of enemies.
And honest, it's just a fantastic game.
Do tell me if I need to change the game sound, I actually have...
Oh, wow, the game sound went up, it should be a little bit less than that.
My apologies, I can't believe Mumme would really use like that.
So Slim Girls actually confirmed, no, I draw the line at Slim Girl.
I know, ha ha ha, funny, funny Slim Girl, but...
Now, this tactic is you take these and purposely go off the map.
Now you will take health penalties, however, the biggest thing to remember is this is actually a child's game.
The odds are you're going to get your health back via a fight.
Please don't worry too much about any kind of tactics that you might use.
Where the heck is... is there not three?
Oh my god, I'm such a fake cameo player, I didn't know that there wasn't three.
What the heck?
You're supposed to get on my back.
Yeah, I was going to say, you get plenty of opportunity for health in this game.
You really do.
No, I can't just do that.
I'm currently getting bumped by a fire guy, which is a bit annoying.
I hear him! No, I missed!
And I missed again, oh, and I missed again, oh, and I missed again.
There we go.
Get off the map, bro.
But yeah, as I said, this is a fantasy game.
It is a childhood game and it is a child's game, so there's nothing to advance enough at all, which is really nice.
The child's back is bro.
Wait, this guy compares people on his back and throw them.
Honestly, it's so hardcore.
This game, ow, that hurt, don't do that again.
Only I'm allowed to punch.
Oh, we entered slow time, but we already defeated the enemies.
The game hasn't registered they're gone yet, so we're just going to stare at them in slow-mo.
Eat.
But yeah, I love these tips and tricks.
Did you see Brotherhood so well?
I'm like a fan of the game, I must say.
I guess who fell asleep listening to myself last night?
So I normally listen to the binding of Isaac's gameplay to fall asleep to.
What a fucking mistake it was listening-
Oh, pardon me.
What a mistake it was listening to myself to sleep.
Sorry, my feet are a bit bigger than I anticipated, my apologies.
I kept waking myself up in a weird hazy dream.
I could hardly make heads or tails or anything.
I was drifting away and then all I heard was,
Oh, cursed eye!
I'm like, holy fuck, who the fuck listens to me to go to sleep?
I'm so un-relaxing.
I can't even fucking do anything.
It was terrible.
I can't wake up my own self up.
And then I can't celebrate in every decent eye.
Oh my god, I was like,
Oh, streamer luck!
I'm like, fucking hell, who the fuck is sitting listening to me in the background?
I'm like, the only-
No wonder folk listen to me at work.
It's not like you can listen to me fall asleep to.
Honestly.
Please never change.
It was a really good run to be fair.
Bro, I was like trying to sleep.
I'm like, who the fuck is going to sleep listening to me?
I'm like getting so excited.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Oh wait, we need to be pummelweed for this fight.
Ice fight guys, so versatile.
Chinchilla is just fantastic.
So we're going to purposefully lure him over here.
And the reason for that is because there's two enemies behind
those triple bot- Oh, I missed.
Sorry, I'm like selling a thought that was a bit closer.
A bit closer than I anticipated.
Now, you can do this in one if you get lucky,
but unfortunately I hardly ever get an opportunity to do this in one.
Yeah.
But you can, again, just do his weakness straight up with that.
No problems.
Absolutely no problems.
You're simply too hard because you're talking about yourself just like,
What?
I can't- No, like I can't wake in myself up.
I was like, oh my god, shut up.
I have like a timer that I can play.
So it went on, like the TV went off after two hours of listening to me.
But literally I can't wake up.
I was like, oh my god, I can't handle this.
Right, we've got cutscenes so I should be quiet.
I've got a cup of tea.
So I'm going to slurp it and hope I don't vomit it up
because I don't know what's going on with my stomach.
I'm doing an Emmy where I should have.
I love when Emmy just casually comes out.
She's like, yeah, I got IBS and stuff.
I don't know if she does have IBS,
but the amount of poopy caca stories I keep consuming of hers,
I'm like, did I need to send you a doctor?
Don't think I won't do it.
A fellow sleep-
You fall asleep to me all the time.
You must have me on low volume.
Okay, so that's my sister.
That's my family.
Well, she's not really my biological sister,
but it doesn't count, okay?
That's my mohen.
That's my evil sister.
You can tell she's evil because she's got big rack.
I'm just kidding.
And then that's the evil, evil guy.
I really slapped the souls out of you.
Literally, they yoinked my elemental powers.
Give them back.
Pa, Koopa.
Thank you for coming to Membership.
Member, yes.
The broken body was found by the castle servants
and brought to my hut.
It took all my powers and strength
to bring back from the brink of death.
You know my out-and-child.
I'm not a child, and yes,
I know that I missed one of the most
long-lived bodies.
Very good.
Now, would you like to explain
why you're stronger than any possible
because I didn't have time to sit around
and wait for some other hope to be repeated?
You were the one who went far from the what-not.
Your power over the elemental warriors
would be weakened.
I don't have much to worry about.
You guys are showing your support.
The return on investment
I had to try and rescue them.
is coming on very quickly.
We quicker than anticipated.
I have good reviews.
Lister Tail didn't make it.
I'm curious as to why...
This is Rare's worst game?
Oh, you didn't enjoy it?
That's such a shame.
Oh, this is a 10 out of 10 game for me personally.
I was going to write a review on how this is like the...
This is a gaming fantasy experience
that is easy to consume,
easy to play,
easy to digest on a quick basis.
You know, some games that...
You know how kind of the rise of games of
oh, you need to open up the Wikipedia
to learn any aspect of the game.
I'm really just so curious to see a positive opinion.
Oh, you know, as the rise of games
where you need the Wikipedia to access
and even comprehend what you need to do.
This old, much older developed game by Rare Studios
A celebration tip.
Oh, Broly Legend, thank you.
You don't need to celebrate.
What the f***ing thing?
But thank you for the tip nonetheless.
This kind of game also encapsulates fantasy,
especially for...
I would say...
I'm going to say it will be controversial with my words here,
but I'm going to say this girl is more geared...
This girl...
This game is more geared towards the girl
because like, I get to play a beautiful fairy
and I like...
I don't know, I just...
Everything looks good.
Her design is fantastic.
It's not over-bexualized.
Like, it's not that kind of game, you know?
Like, you may be like,
oh, but cameo's a stick.
Like, no!
Her design is 10 out of 10.
And like, you've got this cool, like, money aspect,
but it's not...
There's nothing like, you know, we press...
Oh, wait, I've not got the what-not yet.
Hold on, hold on, go back, go back.
No, don't quit.
Eh, right, we've not got the what-not.
But like, look, you could see it at a glance.
Look, we've got a health bar, we've got a spirit bar.
You know, there's not too many complications
in how to utilize the gameplay.
Oh, here...
Oh my God, I love this bit, sorry.
How can you change that?
How are you going to react to model on?
Get that on.
Oh!
Oh my God!
Why are you giving me money for the girl's done well?
What the fuck?
Why does this happen every time I tell you guys
good news about the girls?
Thank you for the tip.
Fuckin' $100 he does, whoa.
And Galloway Glass, thank you for coming,
a member as well.
Yeah, so...
This happens every time I'm like,
oh, so the business is going good.
And you guys give me money for the business going good.
No, motherfucker, that's not how it works.
You need to wait until I give you an exchange of something.
But yes, on top of like design elements of this game,
obviously you can't say it's a victim of its time.
But like, look, oh, there's a little red thing.
I'm going to grab it.
Oh, how simple is that?
We get a little reward for doing that kind of exploration.
Like it's so basic and it's so simple.
And you know, just like you can explore around the houses.
You've got people to interact with from different regions.
They're all in the magic kingdom.
Like, it's just life is bloody good, you know?
Oh, it's the whatnot.
But thank you, whoa, for the tip.
Yeah, there you go.
Is there pantieshots?
Oh, there's also cosmetic outfit changes.
That's just me.
I like dressing me up.
Okay.
I like dressing Kamiwak.
She's the super thing.
But you've given us more than we could ever repay.
Bro, I'm in so much ASMR debt,
but the next one's a collab and then it's a celebration.
What do you mean this content is good?
I hope so.
Like, I'm just doing me Broly legend.
Like, you know, I think it's kind of easy to tell
that I'm not really chasing game trends at the minute.
I'm just doing my thing and showing the games that I like.
But I miss games that look like they were a joy to me.
I'm really struggling with the audio.
I think we need the what not to alter the audio.
You will not survive what is to come.
Maybe it's my outfit.
Hold on a minute.
Broly legend.
Boy, I've not even done the DEMP audio.
I'm waiting on our VPNG and then I can render it.
And then I need to do a 3K celebration,
which is technically the 5K,
because I wasn't allowed to do my...
No, my hand clapping ASMR.
Hand clapping.
And then I wasn't able to do my burping ASMR reward
until my warning has gone off my channel.
That's what we love about you.
Strongly you do your own thing.
Thanks.
It's the autism.
That's terrible.
But thank you though, unironically.
It's nice to not feel like,
oh, I have to do this.
I have to do that.
Like, I get to do my own thing.
I'm focusing on ASMR claps, other creators.
So I'm finishing my tea before you go.
Early 2000s was peak innovation.
Mmm.
Now, I do apologise if the bit rates a bit on stream
is because I am having a streamer's game.
It's not actually on my PC.
It's on a...
Don't worry.
I won't hit back.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I need my glycon.
Oh, there we go.
On a pumpkin.
Any pumpers?
If you pump someone in Scotland,
it means, yeah, bang.
And if you root someone in Australia,
And if you eff someone in the English language,
it means, yeah, bang.
So when I go any pumpers,
you say, yeah, I mean, I'm a pumper.
Pumper?
I hardly even know her.
Thank you.
I'll just be sorry you're late.
You're just going here for the fun.
Oh, you're in for a fucking treat,
you're free papa.
You're joking?
One of my goals is to get 100,000 gamer score.
You are going to be exposed to many a game.
Some Xbox exclusives and some just play via Xbox.
Amazing joke.
Thank you.
I'm the paint dry simulator.
You know what?
I'm going to develop that game
and then I'm going to market it to VTubers
and I'll be like, get your audience
to prove that you're the Kama Oshi
by literally watching paint dry
and then they'll be like a little timer
and the streamer, all the streamer is supposed to do,
is supposed to be like Zatsu behind in the background.
Okay, so this is The What Not,
the all knowing book that will help me
not only utilize my elemental heroes
but help me swap between them
and also give me help
and show me what I'm missing.
Now today for a membership stream
we are doing a script writing of a devious nature
but that's not going to stop me from pumping in sometime
and Kama O.
So the plan is Kama O for four hours
if I don't just absolutely blow my ass out.
Well my stomach doesn't feel as bad.
And before it was starvation
and I couldn't tell it was starvation
and why my stomach was sore,
I wouldn't be surprised.
But thank you again, Yufu Pappa for the tip, yes.
I'm playing a lot of Xbox games.
Now that the...
Sorry, I'm completely talking over the plot of this game.
Elemental sprites and warriors
are what those people we control,
that's what pummelweed is, etc.
and we lost them all
when that troll did that big old double hand
on us.
You ever played an old game called Whacked?
I don't recognize that name unfortunately.
Starvation.
I wouldn't, I forget to eat so much.
I've got water with me.
Please hydrate as well along with me.
I'm going to try and force myself to have way more water.
My pee has been next to orange and steady yellow
and I'm like, bro, I am causing irreversible kidney damage
because I'm forgetting to drink water.
That crystal eye is huge.
Literally like, damn, couldn't shave it down or something?
Like, geez.
You know blacksmiths can like, raise her down
that kind of stuff.
And yeah, please eat.
Well, my stomach feels fine after that tea
and I don't want to upset it with food
in case it is an issue with my tummies.
Love Whacked, it's like Smash Bros on acid.
Oh no.
Dialysis machine on thrown when?
We're not quite there yet.
Chippy tea, chippy tea, I want a chippy tea.
Well, but you gave me posh nosh, you don't agree with me.
What the fuck are you on about?
I don't want lobster there, my door, with raspberry culis.
I'm a working man from Lanarkshire.
What the fuck are you spitting in the chat right now?
Let him know, you tell him.
To eat daily. Broly legend, thank you.
Yes, I will eat after cameo.
I think I have some bale eggs,
but thank you very much Broly Legend for the tip again.
Montus is miserable.
He just starts spitting in the chat, honestly.
They draw their power from the shadow realm
and must return every so often.
The shadow realm.
Oh.
I'm scared.
Oh, is it Monty Python?
Eat.
I need to put up the rest of my streams this week.
I only managed to put up today and tomorrow's
because I felt very ill yesterday, I don't know what.
So basically, my goal was like,
I'm going to edit three audios
and I'm going to do this behind the scenes,
I'm going to do that behind the scenes.
I did one audio and then felt violently ill
and lied down and I was like, hmm, something's not adding up here.
I can't believe it.
Time to get the suck.
So we get sucked in.
Vore.
Vore confirmed for Gen 2.
Question mark?
I always forget to eat and my mum has to remind me,
my mum has to remind me.
Good job chat time as well.
Reminder to engage in home meal status on a regular basis.
Oh, pummelweed tiny, so cute.
Oh my God, please, can we get a pummelweed for Gen 2?
I'm not even kidding.
I...
Baby pummelweed?
I just love them.
Sorry, I need a little weed for Gen 2.
Hold on, sending those notes on right now.
So we're just waiting for the light trolls to spawn.
We can't attack this guy until a light troll comes in,
just like that.
Make it a flower girl Digimon.
Sadly, I never consume Digimon.
So we need to wait until the light guy doesn't get too close to the target.
It's walking to the light.
Pummelweed.
It gets so loud at this part.
Oh my God.
My heart.
You're so fucking tiny and adorable.
Look at your wee pom-pom on the back here.
Sorry, but I'm just straight up yonking that design.
And we got our fucking 20.
Jeez, let's go Xbox, let's go.
Let's go Xbox, let's go.
Oh my God, I need pummelweed.
I need a pummelweed.
I'm sorry, I do.
I'm saying it.
We're getting a pummelweed.
I don't care if...
It's either Gen 2 or Gen 3.
We're getting something that looks like pummelweed.
Look at the pink gorgeous rose red scheme.
Maybe not this part when it gets so scary.
But like the green complimentary...
How do you not already have 100% achievements?
Because I started on a new account.
Our goal as Stony Cuckoozie is to get 100,000 units going.
Oh, my wee pummel.
Only 50,000 more of those until a million.
A million, no, 100,000.
A million.
We're playing Viva Pinata next week.
But we're playing Jelly Bean game this week too.
Let's spare it.
Let me do uproot.
Jeez.
Stony Cuckoozie Plant Girl for Gen 2 opens up the pollen trope.
The Aphrodisiac pollen trope.
I will admit, I don't mind it at all.
We have to go back to the overbearing mystic.
It's time for another visit to that overbearing mystic.
And before she has cadonkers like...
The Conqueror's Sunflower.
I'll just combine the Conqueror's Bad Friday Sunflower.
And I'm sure there's a flower behind one of these plants.
Zero.
But yes.
We have little pummels.
Did you slay the bees?
Yes.
Don't forget that Potted Plant everyone wants to bet.
Tomboy Plant Girl win.
Allergies intensify.
A little MLR took the plant.
Yeah, we're not doing one million.
We're doing 100,000.
100,000.
But not a million.
A million, I'm sorry.
Stony has pheromones.
I'm pheromone maxing right now.
Did I get a shower yesterday or the other day?
I don't know.
Did you ever play Aragon video game that also came out?
I don't think so, no.
I'm sorry if my error message was coming.
I was just in a silly, goofy mood.
Honestly felt no.
Rare did a lot to bring British humor to the rest of the world.
Oh my god, I'm gonna sneeze.
Ah, bless you.
Do you feel better than me?
Conquer stream win, please.
I do have it on the cards.
The only problem with Conquer is I genuinely might lose.
Like wholeheartedly might lose the game.
And I'm not restarting from the start.
That's my only major concern.
I love how all the confidence chat is coming up with this just tomboy thing.
Not yourself, honestly.
I'm quite happy that I can kinda get input from you guys
because it makes it more exciting rather than just being like,
oh well, no one asked for this.
Well, that was kind of what my debut humor was like.
You asked for a feral kuzugaki.
I gave you a feral kuzugaki.
You asked for a masochistic brocon.
I gave you a masochistic brocon type thing.
That was humorous.
But there are some developmental issues trying to finalize the...
I'm sure there's a fricking fruit.
I knew there was a fruit. You weren't there.
Did I just fly over it last time? I don't know.
But yes, we are gonna give Conquerors as bad for a day shot.
My only worry is that I will fail the game.
And I'm pretty sure it's one of those games where if you fail it,
womp, womp.
Saving content.
Did you play the Hobbit game from 2002?
No.
I didn't play that Lord of the Rings like map game.
In fan technique.
There should be a fruit just chilling up here
unless I've gone to the... yeah, there is.
Oh, actually, I'm gonna go get the Healing Fable Crystal Eye,
which is basically how you smurf this game.
You can literally never die unless you do something silly, Billy.
And what one was it? Is it the second one?
The one over here.
Basically, you can never lose if you pick up this item.
That's why I'm saying this game is just so gamer-friendly.
Have you played Alice Madden's Returns?
Yes, we are totally gonna play that game.
Oh, that wasn't what I wanted.
Yes, we are 100% gonna play Alice Madden's Returns.
I think we'll try and endurance that.
I think the playtimes, like...
Oh, there is. Look at it.
Juicy, Juicy.
We can literally never perish in this game now.
It's one of the favorite Crystal Eyes.
I thought all of those had been destroyed,
but for once, I'm glad I was wrong.
Honestly, me, I'm glad I was wrong.
I'm glad I was wrong.
Me, when I estimated the return on investment
was gonna take six months.
Me, I was glad I was wrong.
Return on investment tomorrow, honestly.
Right, let's just commence.
Gamer-friendly or noob-friendly?
This is like a child's game.
Like, children can play it,
and you can just super run through it if you're an adult
and you bathe in the profit.
Strony stays winning.
You guys have been doing non-stop support.
Now that the debut month has settled,
and now we've entered July,
my focus is on the ASMR videos.
So your inbox is most likely gonna have a lot more ASMR videos
now that things have calmed down.
Let's just commence thought.
Yes. Childhood games like the Minish Cap?
Yeah!
Even though that boss fight is absolutely not for children.
I don't know who the game development team...
I just said gay, I think.
It's trying to pitch that too?
No.
That game is not for children.
That boss fight was intense.
Eh.
Is this a Scottish accent that isn't put on?
Is this...
Is this a Scottish voice
that isn't horrifically put on?
That's getting mentioned in the game review.
Hello?
An accent that isn't horrifically fricking put on?
Am I going crazy?
This game was ahead of its time.
It is still ahead of its time.
Oh my god, we're in a heart.
Look at my voice.
My voice is amazing.
I think that actor is from Glacier.
Dan State is from Glacier.
That guy only appears a few times.
Yeah, apparently he looks like your dad in the game.
Eh, your dad's solo mom.
Never heard of this game, and yet it somehow seems so familiar.
I don't know, he might have watched it in another life.
With another green streamer.
Whenever I tag live streams,
I try to tag someone else that has played the game before.
So I typed in VTuber cameo,
and actually nothing was coming off,
and I'm like, ouch.
Smell.
They remembered Scotland was a real play.
Give it a lick.
Well, the one good Scottish accent in the game,
and it's from a game by literally eons ago.
Okay, my horse is out of stamina, but that's okay.
You're breaking new grounds, honestly.
And no, no.
No horse girl for Gen 2.
I can confirm there's no horse girl,
and I am not interested in developing a horse for Gen 3 either.
So if you're sitting here ready for a...
Oh wait, that's not...
I knew!
I love how far back the camera goes, that's outrageous.
Um, no.
Stop that.
But you want, not even just a horse girl.
You want a Buddha horse girl?
Not only are you brave for your words,
you will be punished for them as well.
Gen 3, old eldritch horror from beyond the stars girl.
It's just a shapeless horrific mass.
Vibles with a pleasant voice.
Oh, we rubble!
Oh, no!
Look at us be around for days.
I've never seen this game before, so you've taken my cami which I...
Oh my god, I'm like talking through the entire plot as well.
Um, long story short, awesome fairy girl needs cool guys to beat up bad guys.
Aw yeah!
So we have unlocked one good guy to do this.
And that's actually how we level up.
We're gonna do razor top, cause that's like by default.
See, we've got little spikes on the top leaves now.
Rubble for Gen 3.
No slimes, what's next, no cows?
Nah, no cows, overdone.
That's why Zura's a goat.
I teased her about having milk and everyone instantly said cow, cow, cow!
No!
A goat!
What's wrong with a goat?
Right, we're gonna go beat up the trolls in here.
Quite literally.
You're free papa!
Five dollars, thank you!
Eh, I have not.
That's not the detective game where you're dead, right?
And then there's like a kid that helps you like solve like the supernatural abilities.
Right?
No, that's something else.
Oh no, put him up.
Get down, get down.
Next you're gonna say no piss.
No, I'm not gonna have a freaking piggy girl.
Rick, you guys wind me up so successfully.
I'm gonna have to start bending yous over and spanking yous cause what's going on here?
Why are you asking for the most obscure, like unsuccessful,
never, like, who's gonna go, oh, pig girl, oink, oink!
No, you have to give people designs that have some sort of fucking element to them that the masses enjoy.
With that voices there could have been a mouse for all I care.
Ah, that's so true.
I agree, bruh.
Is this the threat of our promise?
No chubby girls, and we're gonna, actually, for the designs that have been confirmed,
I don't think any of them are the body type I have originally spoken of.
I don't know, there's a bit of a mix-up.
A mix-up?
There's it, oh my god, there's Beetlejuice on my screen, please!
Beetlejuice, Beetlejuice!
Are you seeing me right now?
Did you hear the random Northern accent?
They gave the plants for some reason.
Thank you for the five Galloway glass.
Literally, why on earth did they give them, oh, cool, that's thrill.
Damn, the spider girl.
Bro, if we're getting a spider girl, I'm just giving Amy a whole new model.
Why the fuck would I do that to her, that's not nice.
Yes, I can say that because she mentioned it to herself.
No, I can't mention it about the others because they didn't say it to themselves, okay?
So don't come at my house and shit on my pancakes, alright?
Then you shit in my kettle.
Johnny clearly doesn't know who Saiyan Capsule is.
Pig girl is women.
Saiyan Capsule? Is this VTuber?
I must learn of.
Robotic?
Happy one, monster.
Oh, thank you so much, yes.
It's officially been a monster stream.
And I need to pump up my ASMR numbers on this channel.
Because it's kind of what is known as my bread and butter, yeah?
A bit of bread and butter, yeah?
One, he's not going to be one shot anymore, I don't think.
No, he's two shot now.
Mummy, do human VTubers exist?
I have sad news.
I have absolutely sad news.
From around these parts, I do what is called pilot in a meadow, okay?
I do everything wrong as a VTuber.
Mel, excuse you.
Oh, I lost my wee light guy.
Give me a minute.
Oh my god, he's talking to me.
He just said, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Take this.
I mean, I got him.
Alien and a monster.
What's a human?
Saiyan Capsule is a furry artist.
He's a very cute pig girl.
Look at me rumble.
I'm sorry, but pummel, pummel.
Oh, you stop dancing.
Do you know when I get inside me or something?
What's going on?
Are you ready to go for a cheat camera score?
In the robot moment.
More monster girls?
Absolutely.
No issue with monster girls whatsoever.
A capybara.
A capybara?
You want me to give someone whiskers?
Right, you're done.
Come on, just take that man out for 10 seconds.
I'm joking.
A capybara?
You guys,
I swear I'm just getting trolled
and constantly falling through the base.
Oh, they actually timed you out.
Yeah, that's what you get for suggesting.
Yeah, that's right. Don't mess with us.
Capybara, a lemur girl.
Someone said lemur lollipop, and I was like,
Honestly?
Honestly, ma'am.
Not bad.
Not bad. I'm not mad at that suggestion.
Unfortunately,
there's no more room at the inn
for gen 2, I don't think.
I think we're going to have to
mother marry this and shove any ideas
into a barn.
But as I said, I do not get annoyed
if you're like, hey, I really like this idea.
I just wanted to throw it out there.
Please don't think I'm going to be like...
I know I'm meme on the slime girls.
I am, unfortunately. No, there's not some
absolutely humongous
ruse when it comes to the slime girl.
And there's one production.
No, there's not a slime girl in production.
I do apologise. I don't care
for it. It's not going to work out.
It's just a good design.
But please do not
feel embarrassed to suggest what is up.
Who goes there?
Funny you mentioned that.
Baron...
Just focus your name.
Baron Ransack von...
Ransack von Joy.
Is this a fucking pun?
Right.
I'm going to say something.
I came across a tweet from the Vealer
because I was having to do some business.
I was having to do some business.
Vealer is going to start celebrating
subscriber milestones
from the girls.
We did it with the 5K
but it's going to be individual posts now
so I'm going to get something sorted out.
When
Vealer was doing the
watch along
we purposefully
put a red herring
in on...
Where the heck is this thing?
on the help
VTuber's watch along
and it was icy with the neck
ears on purpose. Just to fuck
the people because we could.
And a few people bit the bait
and we are not having an echo.
Are these just
are they spawning in anywhere?
Don't worry about us taking any little damage
like that. It will heal with the...
Oh there we go.
The PsyOps.
We did it as a red herring
and we most likely will do it in gen 2
as well so I'm just warning you now.
But yes it was
very fun looking back
at that because I am like 99%
sure I read someone being like
someone thought
Amy was a cat.
And I'm like
she's just the broken.
Yes. Unfortunately
again, neckos no.
Thank you for the tip again.
What did you call it?
Mcgarbage tier, McDonald's
Tier Girl concepts.
Yes. I feel
a bit strongly about
kind of like doing something different.
Now I'm sure you can be like oh but Sheebie
Sheebie's a bunny. I've seen loads of bunnies
before. Right we'll shove them up your arse
then if you love them that. Like if you're going to go complain
sorry but
you can't tell me that Sheebie's design isn't a pure
sex way. Like I'm sorry like what's
going on here?
What's going on here?
Anyway.
Oh I just realized I still
have that Sheebie short pinned.
Oops.
No no don't give me information yet.
I'm not. I only have 20 bucks.
I don't think I can buy anything from
mine.
We'll get the elixir of life
because that increases our health bar.
What you'll do is just tidy.
We can't really upgrade our thing. Way too many
cat girls on the market. Yes.
Unfortunately we're
starting to get
mildly
obscure for gen 2
but the good kind. Not the bad kind.
Not the kind where you're like what up
and were they thinking when they
developed her. The kind where you're
like oh wow that's unique. I'm going to
remember this.
Don't say the H word. I'll
end up reading it out loud.
H
rabbits. You should have a silhouette
gen 2. Well Azura
is Donathan is coming up.
She's going to be picking out the
thing she's doing in it but I'm also going to help her
just a little bit on top just to give her an idea
what she can do.
One of the rewards
is
you guys can pick out
you guys can reveal
a concept from gen 2.
Now there's going to be a
heck of a lot of disclaimers
when the design if she does
reach that milestone. There's going to be a
heck of a lot of
disclaimers just being like
this might not even come to
fruition. This might not
be the finished version. It's literally the first
version of something concepted
you guys will get to see it.
A gen 2.
Just make gen 1 silhouettes black rectangles.
All the designs and indulges are unique and
memorable. I'm glad.
She be
concepted a little emo version
of her and I was like ooh
I see a little something
here.
Can we
just ping it over his head please?
Come on.
Ew.
We'll just spank him a bit.
Take this.
Oh I missed.
Yeah unless you're going for avant-garde
obscure still needs to be recognized.
Yeah it's not going to be like
um
wait
is there any northern English folk
do you guys actually say?
Kill all that little brills.
Kill all that little brills like so save in there.
I want to show you a secret to get past
those sea pits your old barricades.
That was brilliant.
Oh my god would you still love me if I was
actually northern English?
Oh my god you would.
Here we go.
Here we go a little cheeky pommel weed time.
Not me but it's more Yorkshire
than Manchester.
At least tea bit of a cup.
Right we're going to use the fire
to our advantage here.
So this guy
will burn himself on the fire
if I don't mess up too much.
Oh we need it. Wait what?
I was going to say hold on a minute
don't you have to come out now?
Wow take this.
Oh I'm on fire I'm like proper on fire
Did you see that?
Not only Scottish mummies can satisfy me now
oh yeah.
Only I can do.
You must be so pent up then
aren't you?
It's more northwest.
Oh no, northern west of that around here.
There's going to be this guy up
sorry.
He's perished.
Oh there's a sniper.
Oh where are you going?
Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hold on
stop moving stop moving.
I ain't even there yet relax.
Here we go.
What about a girl for gen 2?
Like she's a girl, I've no idea.
Is that all?
Bless you Reiflin.
You're like I'm trying my best.
How about a girl? Yes. Can confirm girl.
Absolutely no problems
with having a girl for gen 2.
Yeah not a problem.
Hello little child.
We're a bit confused
but we have the spirit in the end.
Let him cook, let him cook.
Insectoid fairy design.
I can't unfortunately have any
insect designs.
There's a few exceptions
but on the ground
scheme of things.
Hello? I'm just getting a bullet right
around there.
On the grand scheme of things
builds are pretty off-putting for the
I do have to ensure that I'm giving
the girls the best chance
because you have to remember
people are pausing
their designs, their IPs
the stuff that they're used to
to throwing wheeler
and I don't want to give anything
I was like oh I can just skip past here
I didn't expect that.
Let's go again. Sorry, sorry.
I'm getting distracted here.
A gen 2 girl. Give her a boy model
Absolutely not.
I remember when I was considering
a male gen, a spin-off
kind of thing.
Sorry, I think
because I'm streaming to
Microsoft servers
it's like can I?
Right, excuse me mate. Sorry
just coming through.
I didn't even try.
They're like I don't get paid enough to deal
with you I'm going to be honest.
I'm just going to do this.
Oh wow, that actually
hit like right.
Wait, did I not have?
Oh wait, hold on. I need a rakbido charge.
Dear lord, it was...it was!
I didn't know
it wasn't going to be shared with wheeler
like it would be a completely different
bin-ness. Wait.
Oh, I thought my screen was cut off there
I was getting nervous.
I'm spanking them.
I'm spanking them. There we go.
Oh my god, it's replaying. I didn't
know you guys were in the game.
It's just because
I had no idea how far
wheeler could or couldn't go
but if the return
on investment percentage is anything
to go by
yeah.
My donor
son really isn't going to be much
at all for confirmation of the
Gen 2
production.
Wait, why am I here?
I think I need to activate the enemy?
No.
I'll just do that.
Oh no, they didn't get him.
I'm getting beaten up.
Wait, let's get him.
He's stuck.
Oh, he's stuck as well.
Wait, nature's helping me
stop another 10 out of 10 aspect
cameo. Yeah, again, let's go.
Wait, Shadow Wizard
winning?
You've made most of it back already?
Yeah.
If you check out the shorts on my YouTube channel
I actually revealed what the finalised
kind of roughly what the finalised
price of wheeler production was.
Now, there was a few things
that went a bit horrifically wrong so I didn't
maximise, I didn't min-max the
money that was spent
but it was above like 60
US dollars.
And
just because of the insane
support
we've just done so well that
returning investment is like a problem.
I'm not worried,
I'm happy to say that
Gen 2 pretty much
I mean, I don't even know if my
donor son has to be Gen 2 really
in all honesty, it might just be 3D
model related for Gen 1.
We're still
I don't know the best way to do it
with the 3D models.
I don't know how to do it.
The girls might have more experience with 3D
model than me but I actually don't
really understand any of it.
But, that's just me.
We can go further
beyond.
Oh no, I have to defeat these guys
in these spikes. Oh my god, you're taking
my HP.
Ow, don't be so
red.
Right there. Got him.
We've got the second guy.
Just so you get the third guy.
Fortune's probably over in slow-mo.
Let's get him.
Is that everyone? Was it 3?
There's slow-mo faces.
That was so cute.
Oh, he's got a pan on his head.
Oh my god, pan girl.
Do I vote in rank order?
I don't know. I'll see what Azura comes
up with because
she wanted to focus on
doing her donor son herself and I said
you go ahead but
I might tax some stuff on
free audio
access to labs with the girls.
That usual
the usual
stoof that we would kind of do
just in case you forget.
Azura's is definitely a move-out
fund focus so I really do hope
it goes down well.
Can you ignore these fights?
I'm like 99% sure I can
ignore these fights. Oh no, you can't.
My apologies. I thought that last time as well.
Do you ever friend that as a 3D model
and just answer some questions?
No, I mean in terms of
so
it needs equipment and the girls
need trackers and it's like
well
do we do the donor son so the girls
don't need to
get trackers and the full price
is included and then it's the 3D model
and we'd have to find a 3D model
that would do all six of us
because I'd want us to all be done by the same
3D modeler. Again, that's really
awkward to do. I don't know how long it takes
for 3D modeling and
a lot of 3D modelers are like
I will only work with a specific
kind of ref sheet and I'm like
we don't really have that kind of ref
sheet
so I would have to get someone
that knows their
stuff and I would need to go
get price estimations because
at the rate we're going I don't think
my donor son is going to be gender related
purely on the basis of how much support
I've had
I've legit just had so much support
I think it'll be
maybe 3D related
so the girls can
I think I can skip all this hold on
I just need a cheeky rock
to come back
it'll take a few months
yeah so
the girls can
either do it in their own donor sons
but like
with Emi and IC
for example their birthdays are right
at the end of their
contract
and if they didn't want
to sign on for another year like this is
just straight up like talking about how it is
a VTuber business business business business
but it is what you have to consider
so Emi and IC's
donor thons are right at before
their contract expired so for example
if they were like I've had enough
3D funds no no no not like that
not like that you need to wait you need to wait
I need to it doesn't work like that
really like thank you for the tip
it doesn't work like that
what should I do
you know what do this
I've completely forgotten what I was rambling
about
what the heck
was I rambling about
I forgot
don't say that thank you for the 5
sure
I've completely forgotten what I was saying
oh more business though okay yes contracts right
so the contracts at VEIL are expired
like they've got one year
and if they don't sign on but their donor thon
goals are all related to like
outfits that take time to produce etc
like obviously that's a bit of
a
unfortunate
timing
but I
hope like
from what I'm seeing
anyway from what I see
you know
the girls are
doing very well and I hope
I can keep them happy and be like
yes I want to keep my loyalty with
VEIL or type thing
but it's different if they want to just go off
and like go back to their own thing
but like if it was like
they left to go into another vtuber agency
I'd be like oh my heart I thought I did enough
but I guess not
but oh boss fight
sorry I've literally rambled all the way
through the game that we're at the boss fight already
that is our cousin callus inside
hi callus don't worry
we're gonna get you in a second
yes give me one
second
what was that
you should shake out some enemies
oh money
I'm here for as long as you want
my mommy oh I see
stop you're gonna make me great
I hope you're a happy bean
but yes
I completely understand that it's just like
I wouldn't want to hold anyone back
from anything but it would be
nice that like
everyone's happy
and everyone's thriving
like that's the end goal
you know
I really would love to get the girls play buttons
I know it's only been a month
but like you could technically be like
well everyone's already 5%
oh I messed up
everyone's already 5% of the way to a play button
which is pretty
yeah
and I would like to do that for them
I have a really nice
short of mercy coming out about a play button
which you guys will like
her mercy's cooking
short actually did really well
I'm so glad
I'm like someone's short
has to get caught in the
sorry sorry sorry
I'm like someone's short has to get caught in the algorithm
naturally and say mercy's the first one
well actually emmy's got caught
her rat information short was the first one
to get caught in the algorithm
but yes
don't be surprised when you see a lot of shorts coming out
they
screw up ac love
hey get ac love
my little aco
show us your aco
I still can't believe I put that on my debut
I'm so sorry ac
I'm so sorry I can't help but I'm just terrible
and we got 100
gamer score for free
heyless
I thought it was callous
oopsies
your heart
is so grand strong
thank you I hope
I hope it comes across that way
you know
when
when you've achieved what you wanted to achieve
I got my reeflands
you know I just won
end goal vealors world domination
more likely
take down the high table
but unfortunately we're not gonna get there
but we can try
oh
oh thank you so much
anonymous
I believe in you girls
thank you so much
I believe in them too
once the return on investment
is made
which is
coming thick and fast
I would
like to do a vealor
clipping program
which is what
idle n offers
and I think idle n are incredibly fair
setting such a president
of doing something like that
I think it would help with the success
of the vealor girls getting the more subscribers
more eyes on
you know I've seen people clipping the girls
there's a dedicated
icy clipper
shout out to you you know who you are
I've seen your stuff
there's a few people
clipping the girls here and there
and it's just so fun
like I'm sorry but I'm a wee weirdo
and I like go down the clips and look at them
and I'm just like oh my god those are my babies
you never lost your
reflex
no you guys were very patient
thank you
god I wish I was
I wish I was that sexy hunk
of a man there
hat
where's your tummy
your arms are so big
how am I supposed to feed you if you ain't got
nice stomach
the temptation
to become a sheebie clipper
I've not been funny it makes a world of difference
but I think
in either
august or october
the vealor clipping program
might be a thing
so don't be
gosh thank you
oh my god we got 120 gamer score for
that time
oh my god we're gonna get 1000 gamer score
you do not know how tempted I am
to just play through the full game
I
am so tempted
not to split this up into two streams
I'm so tempted
I'm so tempted to do
the stream of this game
I'm so tempted
I fucking love it
we're technically already one fourth of the way through the game
okay
so who can stop you
Gimli
I'll tell you what
when the sun comes up
I'll let the cats out
ooh you wanna play the game so bad
ooh
well
the only problem is the membership stream
would have to go to tomorrow because
I won't have any creative juices however
I can make an exchange
I
have another shorter game that we could
possibly play
I would have to come up with it
tomorrow
I'm listening yes a trade
offer I would
do a short stream tomorrow of some other game
I've not played yet
nothing is impossible
strong is glowing
what do you mean I'm a government agent
I kept
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wasn't it proved
that government agents give
to
to people who
desire locations
what
Viva Pinata isn't short
I would try and get all the achievements in it this time around
I need to show you
that I am a Viva Pinata
what is
my money
I can't
where the fuck is my money
oh there is 100 coins oh that's perfect
we're gonna get a wallet upgrade
glowy behaviors
my favorite clip from
Fallen Shadow
all Fallen Shadows coming back by the way
Shondo's coming back
we're gonna do
50 runes for that
we need 100 runes for the next one
we'll get this elemental fruit
oh there's a second one I don't have enough for it
oopsie that's how we're rather embarrassing
right we're gonna put Ash on
and then we're gonna head to the dungeon to get another
fabled crystal eye
Shondo is back on the 13th of this month
a lot of people
forgot she was British
and everyone thought she was coming back
in December and announcing it
and it was like guys
guys please
why would a VTuber announce that they're coming back
in 6 months
guys
hello
Shondo collab oh
she's very busy girl
probably I'm not gonna ask
Shondo for Shondo very busy girl
yeah she's like the long
height literally
okay we have a little side mission
see that blinking red dot on the map
that if we do not
fulfill this the game will end
unironically and we'll just have to keep replaying the section
over and over again
we are gonna take the horse
why does the horse insist
on the camera angle
insist on like camera now I'm gonna leave
the horse behind just because the trolls
jump on it and I'm like
bruv please get off it
look at
no way you're going for the horse
no I could have sworn those
guys were about to go for that
right where are these tanks
me
waiting for the tanks to pull up
hello
where are the tanks I'm supposed
to destroy I'm here too quick
she never shows her bish
well her mum came on stream and her mum's
like got that fake British accent
I'm like well cannonball
oh tanks
where are you
are you coming are they down here
oh there they are hold on
let's get to it
I could probably
how far can I go with this
no way you got in my way bro
you have like the entire map
now it's okay if I take some damage
it's not a big deal Ellen
I'm healing I'm healing
I do need energy though
okay there we are
and then another one
and then
one down
feels good man
oh what there's three
I didn't know there was three
well unfortunately
I need to wait until my energy's back
before I can beat up these things
oh I was too early
I was too early hold on
I'm getting smacked
hold on hold on
is there one over here
there is
pummel wheat please
please restore your stamina
I know what I have to do
but pummel wheat is refusing
thank you pummel jeez Louise
buddy
gosh that was no
happening he was like
I really need to catch my breath please
brush me
I'm here
and then I need to wait again
because that one's all the way over there
and I don't have enough stamina to get this all the way over there
we're doing it as if you were in my way bro
getting that performance anxiety
one in three elemental covers
yeah I shouldn't do it like that
we're almost there we're almost there
oh we're gonna run out
no yes go pummel
we need
space get the bar
bar bar bar we need the blue bar
to fill up again let's go
and we did it
and now we get to go to
the water temple
we're gonna go back for the horse
because it's so fast on the horse
and then we were all going for the horse
all of my favorite online creators
are from the yuki or vichy bird
well that wasn't a bad performance
mad performance
yeah that legal
he's very happy with that
that win
okay met and follows
you got it but I'm gonna go back for the horse
because the horse
is just patiently waiting for me
in the distance
all these bombs going off and he's like
yeah I'm just waiting for cameo
yep
why does camera always zoom out
when I use the spirit bar
I'm actually gonna quickly go back to the dungeons
because we're gonna unlock
the spirit bar
health thingy
this camera
is getting ridiculous
everything is turning into pixels
there's no way
that's outrageous
yes I would like to do the warp
a loyal pony
how many gens do we get
someone with bigger oh probably
I mean it's actually not on the
I wouldn't say anyone
is gonna have bigger
the whole point of Azura's design is that she
has the milk
of life and the
fertility like that kind of angle about her
I
yeah I actually don't think
someone's gonna have bigger milkers than her
we do have different
things coming in
in gen 2
we peaked so early
I mean
we could always get an inflation toggle
I'll never say no to that because that stuff's hilarious
it doesn't bother me
oh green ash
hello
hi
green ash
is there nothing
the unforeseen boot a toggle
on the floor
anyone small
you would have to be what is going on in here
you'd have to be concaved
dear diary last night I heard it again that mysterious
knocking sound from the door most of the staff had fled
and no one's willing to come down here alone
oh he perished in here
alright where's the other one it must be
in some other location
then this way ah yes
this way
there we go this is what we're looking for
this revives our spirit bar
very quickly
up next
written for someone extremely tall or super jacked
outrageously
sized if you will
in the bootie department
it will be interesting to see
the reaction to
the designs
because obviously
you know not everything can be your cup of tea
it is not possible
as the French say
it is not possible for everyone to
how you say
appeal to the masses
but I am curious
to see
because I said this before but the development team
actually picked
AC's design
to be the most
liked
oh unanimously
AC one time and time again
and then
I want to say
Mercy was next
Mercy and Sheebie were probably on par
with one another
development wise
just with everyone's kind of
thingy
it looks scuffed
the game it's a very old game unfortunately
and
it's being streamed via xbox
this is an old game
it survived the test of time
the mechanics work
I've literally never experienced a lock out
or glitch in this game at all
yeah
each of our fans not losing the blue is best
allegation maybe the giant
tongue homies will get a bone
maybe
bunny bros winning
wink wink
yes
I'm not going to leave it
I'm not going to leave it a mystery
there is a 2-2-2
in every gen
that is the way we are
doing it
I would like to do it
we're going to keep it up that way
so
the 2-2-2
2-2-2 is real
wrong way
we're didn't mess around
this game literally stands at
I've never had
like any glitches
any astronomical failures
any just
and if you want 100%
it's not that hard to 100%
she says
after that one time she was convinced the game was glitched
and
we couldn't 100% it
a 2-2-2
2 lollipops
2 medium and 2 large
I guess
sorry too small to medium too large
the 2-2-2 meta
sorry
I'm so big I can't get in
are you going to get someone else the voice gen
too are you going to do them all too
I've been practicing a few
accents
I've been practicing the Turkish accent
like
I think I'll probably be able to
pull off gen 2 as well
might have to actually get some real girls
in gen 3
but if you give me some time
if you give me some time
I think I'll have gen 2
all voices all nailed down
you know I'll probably
be looking for
an English girl maybe a Filipino
I would like some
different nationalities
come in the mix you know a bit of German
hallo Leute
du bist gut ja
ja du bist gut ja
ja du bist gut
are you a bug girl
I am a cold fish
look
I'm a cold
fish and I can also do
heptosis but I'm not going to do it right now
but I'm a cool fish
and I do my dance
yeah fishy
fish gang gang gang gang
du bist gut
ich bin gut ja
so yeah gen 2
probably going to play a German character
I think that would go where the heck is this
am I going crazy
did I walk past it
yes I'm going
hey let's go
a person that lived all her life
in the Arctic
I mean I see technically
was kind of in the
tum draw a wee bit
just a wee bit
what am I to do
I'm to do that
so you can save yourself
from fall damage
I don't think you have to move this
I think it will always blow up
the thing nearby
technically a cephalopod
well
yeah you're right
you win this time
you win this time refling how dare you
try
the second is for drunks
I have no other German
I have literally no other understanding of German
du bist
ein und du bist einhorn
I play a drunk
right okay drunk German
confirmed for gen 2
eesh eesh
yeah that's the best I've got
maybe a dinosaur girl
for gen 2
about that
please don't be mad at me
when I show you the developmental notes
of gen 2
eee
I may or may not have rejected
a dinosaur
oh we can't even do this yet
cause we need major ruin
du bist ein einhorn
nein
ja
ich bin ein cephalopod
wouldn't say no to an angry ghost
I submitted that and I didn't get it
Stranny why
look
listen
and check the road twice before you cross it
sorry if you're a British kid
all you were taught was look, listen
and cross when
stop looking, listen
I think that was a
right we need to listen to the riddler
speak riddles to me
go
a sword
an anchor
a candle
okay
weapon, anchor
candle, grave
thank you for giving me a hint on the first one game
weapon
where the heck is it
you're a weapon
and then
an anchor
a light and then a grave
you're a light
and then a grave
okay there we go
some kind of golem girl
ah
motherfucker
you guys are gonna even have a heart attack with these suggestions
your thighs are the weapon
Stranny
I will
relentlessly correct your German
okay let's do counting in German
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7
I don't know German at all
I've just given all Germans
like start cringing in their state
they're like what
it's like French as well
I can't count in French
like we know this
1, 2, 3, 4
I just can't do it
I can't do numbers
I can do Japanese up to 10
1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
Spanish